this is an unnecessarily rushed
explanation of the most difficult game
of all time super hexagon so super
hexagon is an iPad game and basically
you just play this game you know just
this little tiny triangle one all you
can do is just rotate the world left and
right use its tiny little triangle
sitting in the middle of this sort of
orange de globe world now the triangle I
mean when you start playing super
hexagon you pretty tap the screen and
immediately what happens is you die you
die immediately and then you fry playing
getting your die immediately and then
it's like game over you want to restart
again you play it again we die
immediately now eventually you're gonna
start to wonder like why do I keep dying
constantly about playing super hexagon
well what you really have to do is make
sure that all little hexagons that are
rotating around your triangle get out of
the way of your triangle as he sort of
he maneuvers through this teeny tiny
little path now once you start to get it
then you can get to like the first game
then of course you die immediately but
you set a new high score your game
lasted for one second now you can try to
go through another gate another great
another game what's I think I'm gonna
end up happening is you're gonna set the
high score of like three seconds and
then it's gonna feel amazing every time
you play super hexagon for like one more
second longer so oh my god I beat my
high score now it's for second now
something really crazy is gonna start
happening as you're playing super
hexagon you're just gonna be sitting
there restarting over and over and over
again and you're gonna stop forgetting
that you leave it playing super hexagon
if you're watching Judge Judy on TV
maybe you're having a conversation with
somebody in the same room but what's
going on is for some reason you look
down at your screen and you're like woah
let it sit like a time of like 20
seconds on super hexagon how did I even
just do this and you're gonna totally
psych yourself out but you're gonna try
again and then you're gonna die on the
first date again you're just gonna
explode why is it I have no idea but
it's like when you get into this weird
zen-like state where you totally forget
to even playing super hexagon that is
the moment at which you will do really
well at super hexagon because even your
brain just starts automatically doing
all the things to me you mean you're not
psyching yourself out quite frankly
there are people out there who will play
super hexagon for minutes they will set
these incredibly ridiculously high score
in super hexagon I think these are our
modern-day Buddhist monks and I think
that if we need to know the secrets of
the lighten magician
ask them right during the middle of the
game a super hexagon because that is
when they're going to give us the
perfect answer